من سيدافع عن ترامب في المحكمه ويواجه كل
هذه الاتهامات التي تثقل كاهل رئيس السابق
والمرشح الجمهوري لرئاسيات 20 24 طبعا
هناك فريق قانوني كامل لدفاع ترامب لكن
عضوا رئيسيا في هذا الفريق جذب الانتباه
اكثر من غيره وهو المحامي والذي يمثل
ترامب ايضا في قضيه نيويورك الجنائيه
المتعلقه بدفع اموال مزعومه في عام 2016
لممثله الافلام الاباحيه
حيث يقود الفريق القانوني للرئيس السابق
من هو هذا الخبير القانوني نتابع في
التقرير
[موسيقى]
اذا اختيار المحامين وتجميع فريق الدفاع
مهمه اولى هرعرع مستوى الرئيس الامريكيه
السابق لاتمامها قبل مثوله امام المحكمه
لكن التحدي الاكبر يتمثل بكيفيه ضاحظ
الاتهامات في قضيه جنائيه قد تكون
خياراتهم محدوده فيها فالحجج قد تبدا
باستخدام نظام القانوني لتاخير القضيه اي
التاكيد على حق ترامب في اخذ الوثائق من
البيت الابيض بحجه انه رفع السريه عنها
قبل مغادرته لمنصبه السرك السياسي قد
يتواصل مع اتهام الادعاء بسوء السلوك
ومحاوله الاثبات ان عمليه هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى التي ادت الى لائحه الاتهام شابتها
عيوب فتصوير ترامب لنفسه كضحيه للمدعين
الفيدراليين ضمن الخيارات اي ما سمي
بالمحاكمه الانتقائيه خبراء قانونيون
رجحوا ان محامي ترامب ومحاميه سيزعمون ان
التهم غير عادله ولم يتعرض لها سياسيون
اخرون كان واجهوا تحقيقا بسب تعاملهم مع
المستندات السريه وبينهم هيلر كلينتون
فالمدعي الفيدرالي السابق واستاذ القانون
في جامعه جيوب سامويل بويل كان وصف معركه
ترامب بالشاقه واي محاوله لاجراء مثل هذه
المقارنات هي خاسره تماما فقضيه ترامب
تضمنت عددا هائلا من الوثائق السريه وادله
مهمه على عرقله لم تحدث مع السياسيين
اخرين كما تقول نيويورك تايمز غير ان
مراقبين اكدوا ان امكانيه تاخير القضيه
بشكل كاف الى ما بعد الانتخابات حتى لو لم
تنجح اي من هذه المحاولات لعرقله التهم
وان فاز ترامب فيطلب بنفسه تخلي المدعي
العام عن هذه القضيه او العفو عنه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات